hi my name is EJ Saiga I'm a senior
kernel developer here at love research
and I'll be talking about the asymptotic
relations that we added in version 11.3
of the Wolfram language
I'll be talking about asymptotic
relations so the plan is to introduce
six asymptotic relations that we added
in version 11 three of the Wolfram
language show some applications and
discuss connections to other parts of
the larger asymptotics project so
asymptotic less equal as we call it
I'll more popularly known as Big O it
was popularized by Paul Bachmann in the
1890s and work on analytic number theory
building on some earlier work and
basically what it says is at a point X
star f of X is less than or
asymptotically less than or equal to G
of X if there's just some constant such
that the absolute value of f of X is
less than that constant times G of X for
all X near X star this captures a notion
that in the vicinity of that point could
be infinity could be 0 could be anywhere
in between could be in the complex plane
that the magnitude of F can't become
arbitrarily larger than the magnitude of
j ji what Bachmann did was he was
studying sums or various other number
functions on the primes and he was put
them up into two parts I can do this
part I can prove this part is ignore bow
so and he used o for orden order so it's
order of this you know n to the K
whatever now it's much more widely known
because of pulk muth and computer
science where it's yeah used in
algorithmic exam and algorithmic
analysis so some very simple examples if
you have some polynomials that sorry ma
nome wields at zero then each power
makes it asymptotically smaller than the
previous one so X to the K is less than
B M X to the L if L sorry if K is
greater than
that am I saying this right I'm sorry
right if K is greater than or equal to L
yes then X to the K is less than X to
the L because you're going to zero
faster and if we look at some plots then
we see yes X to the K makes it 0 faster
the order is reversed at infinity
because as you go up you go to infinity
you blow up faster here's a sort of
cutesy example so x squared or is less
than or equal to x squared times sine of
1 over X plus 2 and that plus 2 is
pretty important and which is less than
X and if we look at a plot of that we
see Y so X is going down to 0 this way x
squared is going to 0 even faster and x
squared is hugging sorry x squared times
sine of 1 over X plus 2 is hugging x
squared as it's wiggling up and down
okay so a little later called little
came along it was introduced by Edmund
Lando not lev landau and so in some
fields and regions these relations are
called bachman londo symbols and the
different it the difference looks very
very similar but in the great world of
quantifiers which quantifier you use May
is very important so rather than their
existing a constant a positive constancy
it has to be for all constant C greater
than 0 and this quantified the notion of
an ignore ball one part was
asymptotically less than or equal to the
other part was clearly less than as
determined by this notion and you could
get rid of it
so well these are the first couple of
examples what very similar polynomials
are ordered now notice that X is not
asymptotically less 10 to the fifth X as
X goes to infinity even though it's a
hundred thousand times
at every single point on the positive
reals it's not asymptotically less
because while there's a fixed constant
there's a constant offset in on the long
log plot or you know there's a constant
ratio which means for very small C's you
can't make the C arbitrarily small it's
bounded away from zero right so
similarly x squared is not
asymptotically less than or equal to x
squared sine of 1 over X plus 2 but it
is asymptotically less than X and now
there's one oddity of this definition 0
is less than or equal to sorry 0 is less
than 0 because we have to satisfy this
inequality here where we have a less
than or equal to for all positive
constants you have 0 is less than or
equal to 0 for all C yay 0 is less than
0 okay and then perhaps third most
famous name possibly even second most
famous although historically later
invention is big theta which was
introduced by Kluth in the 70s and it
says now we have two constants C 1 and C
2 and whoops oh no there it is C 1 so we
say C 1 f of X C 1 times the magnitude
of G of X is less than or equal to f of
X which is less than or equal to C 2 of
G of X so basically you can't get too
much bigger or too much smaller than
than the other guy an equivalent
definition is f is a is asymptotically
equal to G if and only if F is less than
or equal to G and G is less than or
equal to F so some examples two
polynomials are asymptotically equal at
infinity if they have the same degree so
I have ax to the N and times BX to the K
and C X to the N times DX to the L and
I'm going to assume that K and L are
smaller than n
you know that a and C are not zero so we
actually really do and really is the
highest order and they're asymptotically
equal here I'm using the alternative
definition where I'm saying each one is
asymptotically less than or equal the
other one so here I'm visualizing three
pairs of equivalent polynomials and
making a log-log plot and polynomials
are sort of nice they approach a limit
at infinity when you take their ratios
that ratio doesn't have to be one I mean
it's going to be five because I have
five x cubed plus Stoffel four x cubed
but it approaches some ratio away from
zero now here's a more interesting case
so x squared is a asymptotically equal
to x squared sine of one over X plus two
at zero that is true and if we look at
the plot of their ratios
it Wiggles mercilessly as we get closer
and closer to zero that's okay because
it's bounded away from zero and it's
bounded away from infinity right we our
constants are basically C well our C 1
is 1 and C C 2 is 3 and they're both
positive and less than infinity if I
didn't have that two plus it would not
longer be true because I would be
hitting 0 infinitely many times and so
you wouldn't be able to make that bound
okay so some applications a famous
application is the analysis of
algorithms this is an illustration of
merge sort I will assume you either know
what the merge sort is or are just
amazed by this picture so it tells you
everything you need to know but the
basic idea is you split up you have a
bunch of numbers you want to sort you
split them up into smaller and smaller
groups then you combine the groups back
but when you group them you put them in
an ordered fashion into the destination
array so the time T event to sort n
elements will be the sum of some
constants some constant time B to
compute the middle because we're
splitting it in the middle to
do you have an over to to sort each half
because it's a recursive algorithm we
split once then we sort each half
combine them and some multiple a n of
the number of elements to combine the
two halves where a and B are two
positive numbers determined by the
computer and your compiler and whatever
else determines how fast these
instructions actually run so we have
this recurrence equation for how long it
takes to run for sorting n numbers our
sort of solve our solve value can solve
that for us and so we get this and in
particular this formula is going to be
asymptotically equal to n log in so what
does this tell us well if you have a any
algorithm which takes n log n time it'll
take roughly the same amount of time
where roughly is some sociological term
but you can expect scaling similar to n
log n for large inputs on the other hand
if you have a sort that can run in time
n like a radix sort that's going to be
faster for large inputs because there's
asymptotically less than n log n on the
other hand if you were very naive and
used the bubble sort which has run time
N squared
it'll be slower because n log n is
asymptotically list and N squared
another family of applications is
convergence testing so basically two
functions which are asymptotically equal
to each other have simp the same
summation and integration properties so
for example arc 10 is asymptotically
equal to 1 over n at infinity and it's
well-known that the sum of 1 over N is
diverges which means that the sum of
arctan as you sum over the positive
integers is not a convergent sum on the
other hand arc 10 over X is equal to 1
over x squared at both 1 and infinity
which means the
one over arctic arctan of x over x is
integral integral over one infinity
because one over x squared is integrable
over one to infinity it's very simple
integral to do in fact equal to one okay
so I've talked about less less equal and
equal so what about greater and greater
equal and the Miss click here so the
curse of the partial order so asymptotic
less equal is a partial order unlike
your familiar less and less than while
it is true that for any two real numbers
either a is less than or equal to B or B
is less than or equal to a that's not
true for any two pairs of functions you
have incomparable functions so as an
example here f is sine of X and G is 1
over X and it is neither the case that f
is less than or equal to G or G is less
than or equal to F similarly if you have
that a is less than or equal to B you
can conclude that either a is equal to B
or a is less than B but that also does
not hold for asymptotic relations here f
is asymptotic is less than or equal to 1
but it is neither less than 1 nor equal
to 1 and infinity so note in particular
disc collection effects means that the
negation of F is less than G is not G is
less than F so here I have not
asymptotic less of F less than G and
asymptotic less of gf the first one is
true the last is false and the same
thing happens for less equal which is
perhaps more surprising because while
the negation of less is not greater it's
greater equal you might think the
negation of less equal is in fact
greater equal but that's not case for
the asymptotic relations so that means
we have two possible conventions for
what does f great
than or equal to G mean is it not F of
is it not of oh and I have that
backwards there is it not F is less than
or equal to G or is it the reverse
relationship and the answer is well
hardly Littlewood used the first one in
their work on elliptic functions and
Knuth used the second one in the 1970s
he was actually aware of the first one
and he said and nobody uses it
let's let's you change the definition of
big Omega and so the winner is
well analytic number theorists continue
to do what they do and use Harding
Littlewoods definition or some friends
thereof because they're actually four
different omegas in analytic number
theory this definition uses as used in
CS and related fields probably some
others so we follow Knuth similarly F is
greater than or equal to G means G is
less than F so for completeness the
definitions are exactly parallel the
only difference is we've replaced the
less than or equal to with a greater
than or equal to in our definition and
again zero is greater than or equal to
zero that will be important so I've
talked about less less equal equal
greater or equal and greater and then
there's this six guy asymptotic
equivalent that seems to come out of
left field and I would say that sort of
equal less equal equal the way I think
about this is equal less equal greater
equal or sort of one triad that's very
popular in computer science and then you
have less greater and equivalent which
are different triad that you need and
the approximation the functions and
that's sort of where we're headed so
this also comes from Hardy hardest work
not the same paper as the as the bit as
big Omega but a follow up one and
basically and so here's the definition F
asymptotic ly equal to G if the absolute
value of the difference between F and G
is less than or equal to C G of X and
for all so I'll make that whoops I'll
make that bold there for all constants C
greater than zero and all X near to X
star now the basic idea is that the
ratio goes to 1
we couldn't define it that way and it
will be pretty easy to see why a
different equivalent definition is that
F minus G is less than F and roughly and
again the intuitive notion here is that
you're making an approximation with
small relative error asymptotic relation
asymptotic equivalence is a stronger
condition to finer a condition than
asymptotic equality so if your
asymptotically equivalent then you're
also asymptotically equal they're both
equivalence relations but on the other
hand if you're asymptotically equal does
not mean you're asymptotically
equivalent we saw that already X to the
5th + 5 X to the 5th are asymptotically
equal but their ratio most certainly
doesn't get close to one so examples the
one of I think the two canonical
examples are Sterling's formula for the
factorial function it is asymptotically
equivalent to the factorial function
this square root of n times n over e to
the n it is approximating with small
relative not absolute error fact if you
calculate the absolute error it blows up
as n goes to infinity another famous
example is the prime number theorem
asymptotic equivalent is prime prime PI
+ x over log X the distribution of
primes is RS emphatically equivalent in
fact their ratio goes to 1 and again
this is an approximation in small
relative not absolute error so a
different example one
asymptotically equivalent to e to the X
at zero here we have both small relative
and absolute error more on that in a
minute and here relative error makes no
sense but since it's an equivalence
relation zero had better be equivalent
to itself but you can't take the limit
of zero over zero as X goes to a so
that's why we needed this more
roundabout definition right right and I
don't think it's an accident that sort
of the two canonical examples are number
theory examples given that this idea
sort of came out of work by Hardy so
power series asymptotic scales and Moore
and I'm running low on time but I think
I can still do most of this so let's
look at the case Taylor polynomial or
Maclaurin polynomial of e to the X and
just to refresh our memory there are the
first five well e to the X is
asymptotically equivalent to each every
one of its Taylor polynomials in fact
that's basically the content of Taylor's
theorem or at least it's a consequence
of Taylor's theorem but there are lots
of other polynomials with which are
asymptotically equivalent to e to the X
so what makes the case one the case
Taylor polynomial better well to see
that we need to compare the the
difference in the approximation not with
respect to e to the X but with respect
to X to the K and we see that the error
is small with respect to X to the K if
we chose some other polynomial like 1
plus 2x plus 3x squared well it's small
with respect to 1 equivalently small
with respect to e to the X but it's not
small with the absolute errors not small
with respect to X or x squared
in fact the linear Taylor polynomial is
the unique linear polynomial that has
small error relative to X that's what
makes it the best linear approximation
so I'm running out of time so I will
just mention very quickly that this X to
the K is called
the power scale is a notion of an
asymptotic scale where you define a
bunch of functions each one is smaller
than the previous one
so the power scale is one of them then
you have the Laurent scale if you
include the negative ones sometimes
called the Laurent scale so scale means
you have fractional powers a fixed
smallest denominator and here a couple
of crazy exponential power guys and
where did these come from
well just very briefly we have these new
asymptotic solvers D saw value
asymptotic integrate and asymptotic
solve is coming soon and they produce
answers well what they do is they choose
an appropriate asymptotic scale and then
they expand in that scale and what it
means to expand in that scale if there
is an expansion using the scale there
may not be but if there is one it's
unique that's what it means to have an
asymptotic expansion with respect to
this scale may not converge it may not
do lots of other things unlike Taylor
series which are wonderful and uniformly
convergent on compact subsets and all
that other stuff but it is a unique
notion of ever increasing approximation
so that's basically my talk I'd like to
thank Devendra who who is a member of
our team and Adam who's also up here to
answer any questions you may have
I wrote a blog post so those sections
which I had to skip in the interest of
time you can see some more details in on
the blog post and are there any
questions